c'est l'heure du journal de l'Afrique
soyez les bienvenus sur France 24 à la
une ce soir c'est long fil d'attente
devant les stations services en Tunisie
les automobilistes doivent faire face à
une pénurie d'essence liée à la baisse
des importations et de
l'approvisionnement dans le pays les
autorités avaient pourtant promis un
retour à la normale des lundis
la grève des médecins en République
démocratique du Congo et ses
conséquences sur les patients le
mouvement a démarré en juillet dernier
sans qu'aucun accord ne soit trouvé
malgré les discussions entre syndicats
et autorité reportage à suivre dans ce
journal
la démission du Premier ministre au
Tchad après la prolongation de la
période de transition Mohamed Idriss
débit avait été investi de nouveau pour
deux ans et autorisé à briguer un mandat
présidentiel quelle est la réaction de
l'opposition quel impact aura cette
prolongation sur la stabilité du pays
autant de questions que nous posons à
notre invité à minidris spécialiste du
chat
[Musique]
plusieurs heures d'attente pour faire le
plein les Tunisiens sont confrontés à
des pénuries d'essence depuis plusieurs
jours le ministre de l'Énergie avait
pourtant annoncé la fin de la pénurie
pour lundi ce manque de carburant est
causé par la baisse des importations et
de l'approvisionnement les détails avec
Caroline lambolie
des fils d'attente interminables c'est
désormais le parcours du combattant pour
trouver du carburant dans la capitale
tunisienne dans plusieurs stations le
plein est limité à 9 euros soit environ
13 litres
la situation m'affecte beaucoup quand je
me lève le matin ma seule préoccupation
c'est comment est-ce que je vais faire
le plein comment je vais pouvoir aller
au travail et en plus déposer mes
enfants et ma femme
le travail est à l'arrêt nos vies sont à
l'arrêt tout est perturbés ça fait une
heure que j'attends à cette station pour
faire le plein
la ministre de l'Énergie avait pourtant
annoncé la fin de la pénurie lundi grâce
à l'arrivée d'un nouveau navire chargé
d'essence à Bizerte ville côtière du
nord elle a évoqué des problèmes de
distribution au niveau mondial mais elle
a également pointé du doigt la frénésie
des consommateurs tunisiens
c'est l'argument répété sans cesse par
le président Caïs Sayad qui accuse les
spéculateurs et la ruée des
consommateurs plusieurs produits tels
que la farine l'huile végétale le sucre
et même l'eau en bouteille sont
désormais devenus des denrées rares et
alors que le pays fait face à une
inflation record beaucoup ne peuvent
plus se permettre d'acheter ces produits
cette grève des médecins en République
démocratique du Congo les malades
s'impatientes certains n'ont pas vu leur
médecin depuis le début du mouvement il
y a 3 mois les discussions sont engagées
mais pour l'instant aucun accord n'a été
signé reportage à Kinshasa d'Aurélie
bazarra qui manga
aujourd'hui ce médecin congolais ne fera
aucune consultation
donc ça m'a fermé comme de nombreux
collègues il a rejoint le mouvement de
greffe qui depuis trois mois paralyse
les hôpitaux publics les grévistes
réclament la régularisation
administrative de 6000 médecins et une
augmentation de salaire
jusqu'aujourd'hui je suis au grade avec
avec lequel j'étais engagé donc je suis
encore comme médecin interne et je suis
payé comme médecin interne ici à
l'hôpital général de Kinshasa seul les
patients qui ont besoin de soins
d'urgence sont prises en charge un
service minimum insuffisant pour les
patients
ce sont les infirmiers qui nous changent
les pansements je souffre je n'ai pas vu
de médecins depuis trois mois je n'ai
pas l'ordonnance pour prendre mon
traitement
il faut vraiment que les autorités
entendent les médecins pour que cette
grève s'arrête
pour mettre fin à cette crise des
discussions ont été engagées entre les
autorités et le Syndicat national des
médecins mais jusque-là aucun accord n'a
été trouvé
réellement dénuer cette crise parce que
le médecin leur place ce n'est pas chez
elle à la maison le médecin de leur
place n'est pas à la rue le médecin leur
place c'est au travail les autorités
congolaises affirment que des avancées
ont été faites le gouvernement aurait
promis la réactivation des avantages
sociaux mais sans la signature d'un
accord les médecins maintiennent leur
grève
cette information qui inquiète les
autorités sanitaires en Ouganda la 19e
victime confirmée de l'épidémie d'Ebola
est décédée dans un hôpital à campala
vendredi dernier il s'agit du premier
décès du premier quart répertorié dans
la capitale depuis le début de
l'épidémie le 20 septembre dernier le
patient serait entré en contact avec 42
personnes avant son décès le président
Yoeri mossievini doit s'exprimer demain
à la télévision publique
et on vous parle ce soir du Tchad après
la prolongation de la période de
transition de deux ans à l'issue d'un
dialogue national rejeté par une grande
partie de l'opposition et des principaux
les groupes rebelles ma matrice débile
l'homme fort du pays et non seulement
maintenu à son poste mais il est
désormais autorisé à se présenter à la
présidentielle il avait pourtant promis
à son arrivée au pouvoir de se tenir à
l'écart de ce scrutin pour en parler
nous sommes en direct de Dakar avec un
minidriss analyse politique et
spécialiste du Tchad bonsoir merci
d'être avec nous
bonsoir merci de me recevoir sur votre
plateau alors on a vu ma maty Driss Déby
prêtait serment il était en tenue
traditionnelle il a mis de côté sa tenue
de général son treillis est-ce est-ce
que cette prolongation de deux ans de la
transition n'est pas finalement une
période pour asseoir sa légitimité de le
rendre présidentielle
ment cette période
de transition supplémentaire de 2 et
préparer les élections avec la mise en
place d'une loi électorale d'une
commission électorale des recensement
électoral et puis l'organisation d'un
référendum conceptionnel mais et puis
des élections générales mais en réalité
vu que le président du Conseil militaire
de transition et désormais lui-même
éligible on peut dire sans trop de
risques que l'objectif affiché dans son
camp et de le rendre présidentiable en
passant j'indique que j'avais totalement
prévu ce résultat dans un livre
apparaître d'ailleurs dans quelques
jours et qui va discuter longuement des
différentes stratégies des états majeurs
et les parties
voilà donc la réalité je dois dire
largement dépasser d'ailleurs mes
prévisions alors l'opposition et les
principaux groupes rebelles je le disais
non pas pris part au dialogues national
qu'elle pourrait être leur réaction ce
matin le Premier ministre a présenté sa
démission d'émission acceptées par le
Mahamad débit et les rumeurs sur la
nomination de succès massera pour vont
bon train il pourrait accepter on a pu
entrer en contact avec lui il nous a
confirmé qu'il avait lancé une
consultation sur les réseaux sociaux
pour avoir l'avis de ces partisans et
donc la question est lancée le leader
des transformateurs n'exclut pas
d'être à la tête d'un gouvernement de
réconciliation nationale
je dois dire que le dialogue national
inclusif approfondément la miner
l'opposition au chat le camp du
président on a joué d'ailleurs toutes
les tactiques en parvenant à ramener
autour de la table des personnes qu'on
voyait irréductibles comme les
politiques militaires toutes tendances
confondues d'ailleurs à l'exception des
factes et puis du ccmsr le camp du
président
du groupe des opposants combien il y a
d'îlots et de la société civile comme
moi qui Tama ils l'ont toutefois pas
réussi à faire fléchir les facs et
jusqu'au Cayenne d'ailleurs de
transformateur donc ce n'est pas sûr que
les deux années qui vont venir vont
braquer davantage les factes ou les
transformateurs les premiers sont des
politiques au militaires avec un
objectif qui a toujours été celui du
renversement du régime actuel comme
condition de l'alternance et les seconds
ils sont restés ils étaient restés égal
à eux même jusqu'à hier et on a vu
d'ailleurs venez de l'indiquer le succès
a commencé à parler de clarification
d'une part il a même lancé un sondage
une consultation comme il le dit pour
demander à ses militants s'il doit oui
participer au bon niveau gouvernement en
tant que Premier ministre donc tout
jamais là d'ailleurs et dans
l'expectative et attend de voir ce que
Mama dit nous est succès ma soeurs vont
finalement décider donc pour répondre à
votre question non je ne pense pas qu'il
y aura des crispations supplémentaires
en revanche il y aura beaucoup de
clarifications probablement de nouvelles
alliances qu'on pouvait croire contre
nature il y a encore quelques jours je
ne serai pas étonné de voir une alliance
circonstancielle entre mastra et débit
pour la période de la transition
histoire de permettre la Massa
d'ailleurs le mieux préparer sa campagne
électorale une campagne demande beaucoup
d'argent vous le savez et je ne vois
donc aucune crispation à l'horizon à mon
avis du côté des opposants civils en
revanche les oppositions armées vont
probablement continuer dans leur logique
de base alors qu'en est-il la communauté
internationale qui se dit préoccuper de
la situation au Tchad mais qui ne
condamne pas cette prolongation de la
transition alors que ces pays et
notamment la France
condamne en général ces prolongations de
transition après des coups d'État que ce
soit au Burkina Faso au Mali ou en
Guinée pourquoi ce deux poids de mesure
au Tchad
vous savez dès le départ en 2021 le
Tchad avait été présenté comme un cas
spécial à cause d'une part de son rôle
dans la lutte contre le terrorisme dans
la région et puis d'autre part de sa
position je dirais relativement stable
dans un contexte géopolitique régional
plutôt à perturber et donc la communauté
internationale c'était voulu pragmatique
en 2021 et avait donc opté de ne pas
respecter le droit pourtant clairement
rappelé par le Conseil de Paix de
sécurité de lui a donné le mois de mai
2021 et qu'est-ce qui a changé
aujourd'hui je pense que le gouvernement
tchadien n'a pas respecté ces
engagements vis-à-vis des Tchadiens
d'une part et vis-à-vis de la Commission
Internationale de notre il n'y a pas
d'élection la transition sera pour loger
cette fois-ci un président de transition
qui accumule plus de pouvoir il faut
dire que le comité international va et
c'est sans piéger en fait elle avait
donné sa bénédiction à une démarche
juridiquement illégale je crois et
incohérent sur le prétexte de la
stabilité elle voit bien que le pouvoir
n'a pas respecté ses promesses et se
trouve aujourd'hui dans un contexte
géopolitique régional plutôt volatile
plus volatile que jamais avec le bur une
façon qui vient d'avoir son second coup
d'État à 9 mois le Mali qui est aussi
instable et d'autre part de la situation
au chat peut devenir facilement
incontrôlable avec les conséquences que
l'on sait sur le plan sécurité régionale
d'une part sur celui de la stabilité
dans le Sahel voir au Cameroun
d'ailleurs voilà au Cameroun ou bien
même au Nigeria donc le piège est plutôt
complexe pour la communauté
internationale il y a pas de solution du
genre tout est noir ou tout est blanc
enfin pour couronner le tout tout le
monde aujourd'hui a compris où se trouve
le point faible des relations en la
France et l'Afrique il suffit de mettre
un peu d'huile sur tous les sentiments
de frustration et d'accuser Paris de
tout et vu tout le monde descend dans la
rue ce qui rend toute l'action
diplomatique française tendance à
encourager le respect des lois plutôt
difficile car pouvons se retourner
contre elle donc le piège je dirais
c'est refaire sur la communauté
internationale en ce moment merci
beaucoup aminidriss analyste politique
et spécialiste du Tchad merci infiniment
pour votre décryptage
merci
Aminata Touré tête de liste de la
coalition au pouvoir lors des dernières
législatives au Sénégal s'écartent un
peu plus de la ligne de son parti
benoboc Yakar dans une lettre adressée
au présent de l'Assemblée nationale elle
propose une loi visant à limiter
l'exercice des fonctions politiques en
rapport avec les liens familiaux une loi
qui vise principalement le président
Macky Sall la correspondance à Dakar
delimandao
cette lettre adressée au président de
l'Assemblée nationale et le dernier acte
de dissidence se posait par Aminata
Touré il y a deux semaines face à la
presse et l'annoncée son départ du
groupe parlementaire de la coalition au
pouvoir à beno bokriakar évoqua une
sorte de trahison car en état à la tête
de liste de cette coalition lors des
dernières élections législatives le
poste le président de l'Assemblée
nationale lui était destiné une promesse
un non respectée par la coalition selon
elle elle évoque également des
désaccords sur la volonté prêté au
président en Macky Sall de briguer un
troisième mandat en 2024 c'est décidé en
tout cas et de taille 48 ans le groupe
parlementaire de la coalition au pouvoir
benabo kayakar perd sa majorité absolue
à l'Assemblée nationale cette majorité
ne tenait qu'à un seul siège de députés
de quoi rééquilibrer les forces en
présence au sein de l'Assemblée
nationale à moins de 15 mois de la
prochaine présidentielle en 2024
ce mardi marque la Journée
internationale des fillettes l'occasion
pour nous de nous intéresser à leur sort
dans de nombreux pays à travers le monde
les petites filles sont mariées très
jeunes des scolarisés et sacrifiés dans
leur éducation au profit des garçons
c'est le cas à Madagascar notre
correspondante Gaëlle Borgia revient sur
ce phénomène
le mariage des enfants à Madagascar
c'est plus qu'un fléau national c'est
une norme sociale ici c'est une réalité
quotidienne pour des dizaines de
milliers de jeunes filles c'est aussi un
marqueur de réussite sociale pour des
parents qui marient leur fille à un
homme plus aisé même s'il est plus âgé
donc et les chiffres parlent d'eux-mêmes
à Madagascar on a 44,4% des femmes entre
20 et 24 ans qui ont été mariés avant
l'âge de 18 ans donc on a un vrai
problème social qui prend ses racines en
fait dans un contexte économique
d'extrême pauvreté il faut savoir qu'à
Madagascar une fille c'est un fardeau
pour la famille c'est une charge
économique et donc quant à atteint l'âge
de l'adolescence et bien elle va devenir
une source de revenus pour la famille à
travers la dot la dot d'ailleurs qui
n'est pas négligeable ça va être un zébu
deux ébus ça va être une somme d'argent
liquide importante et donc effectivement
comme vous le disiez en introduction et
bien quand il y a une catastrophe
naturel quand il y a une crise politique
quand il y a une sécheresse un cyclone
et bien ce sont les jeunes femmes qui
sont les premières victimes de tout ça
parce que elles vont être sacrifiées
pour permettre à la famille de survivre
voilà c'est la fin du journal de
l'Afrique merci aux équipes en régime
merci à notre chef d'édition Celia
carrassena merci à nos correspondants
sans qui ce journal ne pourrait pas se
faire et puis merci surtout à vous de
nous être fidèle restez avec nous l'info
continuer sur France 24
[Musique]